-I always forget
how short I am
until I come to your show.
-Nah! You know
how to do it perfect.
-I'm going to totally...
Yeah, I'm going to sit.
-First of all,
by the way, look at this vinyl.
-I love it. Yeah.
This is one of the colors.
We have so many
different colors.
I'm obsessed with vinyl.
It's beautiful.
-I have too much.
But yeah, I didn't like
several different colors.
-You have vinyl when I did
your show
when it was in Los Angeles.
-Yes.
-And you had a record player
in your dressing room.
-Yes, I have them everywhere.
-Do you still have it with you?
-You're our neighbor now.
You're right across the hall.
I know, rough commute today.
-Yeah. Welcome.
-Yeah. I love it.
But I forgot, I was telling
you backstage.
Like I forget,
like, when my show ends
and I'm going home,
like, your show is beginning.
And so I'm running into people
in the hallway and I'm like,
"This is -- I'm not this cool,
but I feel cool." [ Chuckles ]
-Because, you know, everybody.
You're like, "Yeah, what's up?"
-I know, you run into people,
and I'm like,
"Oh, that's awesome."
-Did you have a great
first -- first week here?
-I did, we --
Well, I will say
my very first day, um...
[ Chuckles ]
I -- Look, I was very tired,
and we were working a lot,
and I had -- I had gotten
a venti matcha iced tea latte
and then I was just tired.
I don't know what happened,
but I got on,
it was F4,
the elevator, F4.
-That was classic.
-And I -- Yeah.
It is a -- It is a --
It is one of the most iconic
elevators
ever isn't it?
-Fallon 4.
-That's so funny.
-Yeah.
-Um...
And then I proceeded
to not only drop my drink
in the entire -- Like,
I mean a full venti.
And then it looked like art.
It looked like it went.
It went, like, all over.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And then I knew
there were cameras.
So I was like, I was like,
"Oh, my God,
this is going to be seen
my first time here."
Anyway, I have completely
trashed an elevator.
That was my first -- you --
you now have a rock star
in the building, so.
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah. You trashed.
-By the way...
-Trashed the elevator
on my way in.
-You really did. Look at this.
Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah, no. And you...
-You really did.
-You're not even...
-I've never seen that.
-You're not even getting
the full spectrum.
It went to the ceiling.
-Did you throw it?
Did you slam it down?
-No!
I was standing there and it
just slipped out of my hands.
And I was like,
"What the...?"
And it went --
It went everywhere.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's a great way to..
-You're welcome "30 Rock."
Thank you for having me.
-[ Chuckles ]
-I'm sure I'll be --
I'll be asking you
for favors like "Kelly.
Please come over whenever."
-Oh, my gosh.
You know I love games.
-Come sing a song.
-Yeah I will sing.
I will do anything.
-Yeah.
-Tap dance. Whatever.
-Is there a song,
by the way, that you've sang
more than any other song
besides your own songs?
-Um, probably Aretha maybe.
I don't know. I've sang a lot --
A lot of songs.
But probably
"Never Loved a Man"
by Aretha Franklin.
-Oh, really?
Was that the song you would
sing, like, when you were a kid
like trying out
and going to talent shows?
-Oh, no. Like my very first --
I did do stuff from Aretha,
but my very first song, I ever,
which was a bold song to pick.
I would love to say
I was brave and bold.
I was just stupid.
But I picked "Vision of Love."
[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-Yeah.
-Mariah Carey.
-I was feeling very good
about it and it went well.
It went fine.
But like, I just --
Why would you pick that song
as your first song
to sing in front of people?
I don't know.
-Because you like,
maybe you like the pressure.
-I just love the song.
-Did you ever tell Mariah
that that was your song?
-No. Oh, my God.
So what -- [ Chuckles ]
I did, I did talk to her
because I was like, "Oh, I" --
She knows I adore her.
Because I've run into her
several times
and she's probably got me
on some security list
to, like,
keep me away, but...
-Are you in The Lamb--
Are you a lamb?
Are you in The Lambily?
-I'm a lamb.
I love her.
I love her, yes.
But I --
[ Inhales sharply ]
I did something stupid.
She came on "The Voice."
And we were working together,
and I just --
Sometimes I say everything
that's in my brain,
and I shouldn't do that.
But I was trying to say
because she was like,
"Oh, yeah,
like you're writing, too."
I was like, "Oh, my God,
I know all your songs."
Like, I'm a huge fan of her.
People don't realize
she wrote all of that.
Like not just sang it,
like, she wrote everything.
And she was like, "Well,
we should write together."
And then in my head,
I was just like,
"Oh, yeah,
I don't really write like.
I can't be, like, that
vulnerable, like, in a room.
I usually just like,
write on my own."
And then I walked away and my,
my friends were like,
"Do you, do you realize
you just told Mariah Carey no?"
[ Laughter ]
-Mariah Carey wants to write
a song with you,
and you were like,
"That's not what it meant."
-That's not what I meant.
I meant I'm not the best.
Writing for me does not
come out in that scenario.
I'm usually alone.
Anytime you see my name
on a song, I wrote it.
Usually alone.
Yeah,but you would love to write
a song with Mariah Carey?
-I would love to write.
I love you, Mariah Carey,
and I will --
I will risk it for you.
-Yeah. Yeah.
But I just also
saw you recently.
You made some headlines
because you
rewrote the lyrics to...
-Oh, "Piece by Piece."
-"Piece by Piece."
Yeah. I didn't realize.
it was going to --
Yeah, I just --
Look, I was finding a hard time
singing it, like I was like,
I don't know if I want
to really sing that, you know?
And I'm at a different place.
And I was
a very different place, and I.
-Is it hard for you for have
that happen
in your personal life
when you have the talk show?
-Yeah.
-You're the most open and
talking every day
and you're like,
"Well, now I really actually
have to talk about this
because,
-Yeah, I know.
-...my private life.
-No, totally. And I'm going
to be real with you.
Like, I -- Those were
the last two seasons
specifically were very hard
like behind the scenes.
I don't know
if you've ever done this.
I'm sure you have, because
you've done this for so long.
But, you know, sometimes you
send your representative
because it's like,
I can't show up today.
Like I just have to, like,
go through the motions
and be a robot because I, if
I didn't, I would break down.
So this is -- I'm excited about
season five here in New York
because it's so -- it's --
I'm in such a great place.
My little kids are
in such a great place.
I'm happy, I'm present
in interviews I'm on.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like, yeah.
Because I wasn't.
-I love you, buddy.
I'm here for you
if you need anything.
-Thank you.
-But I was thinking about you.
By the way,
congrats on the great reviews
and success on "Chemistry."
-Thank you.
I saw that you redid
those lyrics and I go,
Oh, my gosh,
that must have been..."
-But now everybody
wants me to record that one.
[ Laughing ] So, I'm, like...
-That version.
-The new version
of "Piece by Piece."
It's like the most requested.
-When I read it,
somebody wants to do,
it's called the healing version.
-Yeah, it's like a --
But you know what?
It is very true.
Because, you know, now that
I rewrote it literally an hour
before I went on stage
in Vegas to like,
sing it because I was like,
I can't sing these lyrics,
but I know people want me
to sing the song.
And so I changed it
right before the show,
and, you know, it kind of
put perspective on me as well.
It's like that was a lot
of pressure to put on someone,
you know, to pick up the pieces
of something of your past.
So it's kind of --
It was a lot of --
There was a lot going on
for me that day,
but it ended up working out.
-Do you get emotional
when you...?
-Do I get emotional
anywhere all the time?
[ Laughter ]
Like, right now?
-Hello, this is my venti.
Hello!
-Welcome to 30 rock!
-I did not want a venti.
I wanted a large.
This is too much!
Now no one drinks it.
-I just, I don't know
what happened.
It slipped. It slipped.
I don't know what happened.
-Wow.
-It was art.
-I mean,
you're doing this.
I go like, ooph.
I think I would get, like,
all kind of like,
I don't know if I'd make it
through the song.
-I don't know, you just do.
-You just do.
-Yeah, you just do.
But yeah,
the audience was really --
My audience is cool.
And they were like, cheering me
on because they noticed,
obviously, I started
changing them.
They're very intimate shows.
And so these are like fans
that have been with me
for the ride and they notice
and then they're all like
screaming, like I'm like,
"Rudy," you know, at the end
of the movie, like making it.
You made it!
-Carrying on their shoulders,
like, "Yeah, Kelly!"
-She's making it.
-She did it.
-It's -- "Chemistry"
is the name of the album.
I love the title.
Did you always know
that was going to be your title?
-You know,
at once I wrote that song.
I kind of envisioned
it as the title for it,
just because it's definitely
a roller coaster.
It's not just a divorce album,
it's a relationship album.
There's the good
and the the bad and the hard.
All of it is in there.
So chemistry
can be good and bad.
-Yeah.
-As I've personally
found out as well.
So yeah,
I kind of knew that.
-I love you have a couple
of guest stars
on this album.
-Can you believe it?
Sheila E. is playing on --
That's right.
-Sheila E. is my...
-I love her.
-She's been here
and she can play.
-And she's also
such a quality human.
Like she's so nice.
I love her so much.
And then I asked Steve Martin
because I knew he played banjo
and I referenced the movie
"It's Complicated,"
which is one
of my favorite movies,
and I've seen it
a billion times,
and I love him so much.
And I asked
if he would play on it,
and I totally thought he was
going to say no, and he didn't.
Yeah. So he's on my record.
-Wait a minute. That's your --
-That's your --
That's your guest stars
Sheila E. and Steve Martin.
-Who am I?
-Yeah I was like,
"I have made it."
-Yeah I'm happy that the new
season "Kelly Clarkson Show"
is back, It's on Monday.
And I thank you
for being here.
And you're going to perform
for us tonight
I think it's actually...
But before you're doing
a special performance
tomorrow night.
-Yes, I am, I'm actually.
This is awesome.
I'm performing -- performing --
Audacy's put together
this We Can Survive concert.
And a bunch of artists
are coming together
for such a great cause,
and actually,
I have a ticket for everybody
in the audience to come.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean it's "One Republic,"
"Maroon 5."
You guys all get tickets.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Giant concert,
Audacy, We Can Survive concert.
-Yes!
-Kelly Clarkson, everybody.
When we come back,
Kelly and I
are playing
a fun new game.
Stick around.
Come on back.